[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well great
hello everyone I'm Christopher Baxter
and I'm multiple we're going to talk
about concurrency in JavaScript with a
particular focus on the Dom now
concurrency is a big topic it's maybe a
complicated topic so let's look at some
of the basics behind it currency is
really it's just a technical word for
multiple parts of a computer program
running at the same time now if your
computer or phone has more than one core
which it does or you have more than one
computer which the cloud does then this
can make things get done much faster
however it generally also makes things
way more complicated
speaking of concurrency you always kind
of have to talk about like the
difference between parallelism and
concurrency they're just the same thing
but someone in the 80s took away the
awesome word which is parallelism and
made it means something very specific
but that doesn't matter are we gonna say
parallelism and concurrency
interchangeable who cares so another
important concept are threats they're
just programs that run on a computer and
there can be more than one threat active
at any given time
now concurrency doesn't require multiple
threats for example network requests can
happen while your main thread is running
and so that's still a concurrent program
but if you have only one thread and your
program can only do one thing at a time
on a given device so we saw call such a
program
single threaded and that's an important
term because web browsers which we're
talking about today are traditionally
single threaded now today they're like
these complicated beasts and they do
many things at the same time but they
very much still behave as if there were
a single threaded so it's a good model
to have in your head the single thread
we call the main thread and very
important is this Jess confit your
JavaScript runs on the main threat by
default so if you write some JavaScript
and it's still running
your browser cannot do anything at the
same time which might be bad because oh
my god we have to achieve 60 frames per
second all the time where does his
number come from
that's basically the fundamental
constant of runtime performance
it's how often on a normal device your
graphics card would like to push pixels
to the screen now humans don't you know
bias to this particular framework frame
rate for example movies traditionally
run in the 24 frames per second
important is that they always run 24
frames per second humans are really good
at recognizing changes in frame rate if
frame rate isn't stable we call that
Jack and jank is really bad because it
makes our you know brains go wild now 60
frames per second leads to another magic
number which is 60 milliseconds that's
just 1,000 milliseconds in a second
divided by 60 which is what do you have
to update the screen right well
unfortunately it's more complicated so
there's you and then there is stuff the
browser does which is a layout style
calculation painting compositing
actually physically flipping the pixels
on the screen and everything in that 60
milliseconds has to fit into that kind
of budget great so let's break that down
a little bit because it's pretty darn
complicated you've got 16 milliseconds a
lot of code to execute and you're trying
to get it all done within this time
frame the important thing to remember
though is that's not just your code your
code runs for a certain amount of time
and the browser needs to respond to the
changes that you asked it to do as well
in that time frame and sometimes we
think about this as breaking it into two
eight millisecond segments the reason is
that the time that the browser needs is
kind of arbitrary we don't know that in
advance and so we shoot for pretty much
the worst case so what happens in this
eight milliseconds we have a lot of
stuff to do and let's hope it's not too
expensive we get a click event that
lands in our UI and after we get that
click event we need to process the event
now many traditional water and
frameworks will then do a state change
at this point so we need to determine
what that new state is going to be that
takes some time after we've created a
new state you need to respond to that
state so this response may be a virtual
Dom diff in some libraries or it may be
a direct mutation of elements and others
later we have to issue the direct Dom
updates it's a lot of work to fit in 8
milliseconds and we don't always make it
so what happens when we don't well we
push everything out so now instead of
being 8 milliseconds we're at 10
milliseconds in this example because my
state change process took two
milliseconds longer what does this mean
for the end user it's not that big of a
deal right what means that we went past
our frame budget because we took 10
milliseconds the browser really needs 8
we're now at 18 congratulations we've
unintentionally and produced a little
bit jank now don't feel bad we all do
this it's common it happens to all of
our applications just don't let it
happen too much right however it's hard
to keep this going and hard to make this
work well across all devices because you
can target the devices that you know but
you don't know the performance of your
application on unknown devices why well
because not all mobile devices are
created equal
we've got a plethora of devices that are
out in the world things from low-end
devices that are sold for $80 brand-new
to high-end devices at $1,000 per unit
and sometimes people hold on devices for
way longer than you would expect a
person buying a phone in 2016 is
probably still holding on to that phone
and the performance of that device has
not improved in fact it's gotten worse
so it's important to remember that the
things that you see are not everything
is not everything that a person using
your application sees so let's go into
this a little bit more in depth pretend
we're walking into a brand new big store
like a Best Buy and we're gonna buy a
new device today it's helpful to think
about a device that you're purchasing as
breaking down into one of three segments
the first segment the first the 15th
percentile is roughly around $80 so if
you were walking in today and you wanted
to spend around 80
you could afford a device in this
specific segment of the market the
second segment is around 75th percentile
where you're looking at spending close
to $600 that's a really large increase
and the third segment is the special
segment I would say because you're able
to spend a thousand dollars on this
device one device a thousand dollars
now this gamut of price is not normally
reflected in our metrics we tend to look
at things as a whole however if you
break things down into these segments
patterns start to emerge so let's look
at single core performance over time
this is a chart of all single core
performance of modern devices from 2011
to 2018
now the segment's are again highlighted
here so blue is the 15th percentile you
might notice that this trend line is not
going up and there's a reason for that
these devices are not becoming faster
they're becoming cheaper and more
accessible and more prolific across the
world these devices are not improving at
the rate that you would expect with
Moore's law the second category is that
75th percentile and this is a pretty
close approximation to what you would
expect from Moore's Law we're seeing an
improvement in performance over time and
these devices can even have specialized
hardware like a pixel does that allows
you to do say machine learning on the
device our third category is worth
talking about as well credit where
credit is due the a-series processors
are fantastic these things outperform
Moore's law by a dramatic amount but it
creates a very large problem for our
industry as a whole the problem is that
we take out the devices that we have in
our pockets and we test the things that
we build on these devices these devices
are not representation are not an
accurate representation of what's
available in the world or what many
people have so this particular gap hurts
end-users significantly and it's
important to remember this very large
performance gap this gap is increasing
not decreasing
there's to be some good news right we
wouldn't be talking about concurrency if
there wasn't some very small light at
the tunnel maybe at the end of the
tunnel
so what's multi-core performance look
like let's look at those same devices in
this first category the 15th percentile
you can see that the green trend line is
slightly improving compared to single
core performance there is one noticeable
exception at the very end of this line
the nokia - it's worth calling out
because there's a very popular phone
that you can buy for $80 in the United
States and it is selling like crazy but
it can't be that bad right I want you to
bear with me we're about to watch a very
long video but it's worth the time here
I have two devices an iPhone on the left
and an unnamed device on the right you
name it it's a Nokia - this test the
Ares 6 test tests modern JavaScript
features for instance one of the things
that it runs is a Babel transpilation on
the device you might criticize that test
by saying no one will run Babel on a
mobile phone and you're right for
criticizing it however it is a good
representation of what runtime
performance is like there's no load
involved there's no network involved
it's pure capabilities of the local
device and it's entirely single core
focused so we've got the iPhone here on
the Left it's gonna finish this test
pretty soon all six passes of the test
are gonna finish at roughly 48 seconds
now I'm going to speed it up a little
bit because it's a bit painful the nokia
2 is gonna be running this test for a
while longer and we're just gonna wait a
couple minutes okay now sped it up eight
times we still haven't finished one pass
of six or six classes
it hasn't crashed I promise a-alright
five minutes and 19 seconds for one of
six passes that's pretty bad
but that's what a lot of people's
devices are like and that's all what a
lot of people are entering the internet
using for the first time all right so
what I kind of took out of these graphs
is performance is not evenly distributed
but there is a chance to get a little
bit more of the devices but taking
advantage of their multiple cores so how
do we do that in JavaScript well super
excited to announce super amazing new
API on it called the web worker which
has actually been around since 2009 do
folks remember Ajax Ian
if the Ajax iam wrote about something
you have to check whether it's still
supported not where the browser supports
it this is this API is in every browser
it's in ie8
it's not a 96 all right so it's not in
every browser but it is in every browser
you care about we can really take
advantage of it so what are they they
are a way to write multivariate
JavaScript in web browsers now you've
probably heard that multi-threading can
be like dangerous and memory unsafe so
this is not the case here workers share
no state at all with each other or the
main threat they have only access to
very limited set of API so they can't do
everything you can do on the main thread
and and it's very important for this
presentation they do not have access to
the Dom and we're talking about
concurrency in the Dom so sad face let's
take a look at how that API looks like
the worker you know you just make a
worker or you give it a Java file and
then it runs and you can send it
messages this post message this kind of
usually looks like this you know you get
some event you send a message to the
worker the worker receives a message
does some computation sense us back we
receive it back we have to compute it I
think one of the main things here is we
have to
be very conscience the right coat like
this we have to measure that we have to
we have to you know do the work ten
years of adoption have shown that this
is not something we do very often right
so there's a problem with this
programming model so the primitives to
low level is there something a bit more
abstracted perhaps usable in comparison
I'd like to go over a few things that
are showing some progress in this space
first ones called Cluny it's made by the
chrome team the way that it works is the
JavaScript you want to run in a separate
thread is actually loaded with your main
thread JavaScript so in this case we
have a class that exists within the main
thread but using Cluny were able to
spawn an instance of that that class
that runs entirely in the worker so what
happens is Cluny underneath the hood
creates a web worker for you sends over
the JavaScript that it needs to be able
to execute in the worker and you can
just await its response but it would be
great if this was actually in the
browser itself right this is something
that feels like it should be an echo
echo script level spec so there's a few
specification outs that are that are
trying to bring this to Ahmed script the
one that I think is the most interesting
is called Jas blocks but it has an M lot
above the O so I don't know how to guess
blex ducts whatever he said so the way
that this one works is very similar to
the last example in the sense that the
block that we're defining here that has
this additional straight lines is
indicates that this piece specific piece
of code can run in any thread it may run
in the main thread and may run in a
different thread it's up to the browser
runtime or the JavaScript runtime in
this case to determine based on system
resources where this should run but this
presents a pretty big problem in
JavaScript because this thing wouldn't
have access to lexical scope it only
knows about the scope of its current
block it can't know about anything
outside of it because it may not run in
the same thread well the proposal
provides some syntax to allow you to
specify the things that you would like
to ensure are available in that within
that specific block in this case
something that looks a little bit like
typescript is included so you can say
for this specific worker instance I'd
like to make sure the end point dogs are
best is passed along let's look at
something a little bit more easy to use
straightforward applies to many of our
applications today many of us use redux
in this room and many of us across the
globe use it from really great earlier
talk today so redux is pretty powerful
but it runs in the main thread so what
happens in that earlier model is we
would need to run our entire Redux store
and reducers for all of those actions in
the main thread stockroom from Jason
Miller is very similar to redux except
that it runs in a worker so your main
thread code subscribes to updates that
come from your Redux store but your
networking requests and your redux kind
of massaging of data happens entirely
off the main thread this can free up a
significant amount of your time and a
web app that uses redux heavily but I
thought this talk was about the Dom you
are absolutely right
so Malta yeah so as I said earlier the
workers cannot have access to the Dom
which is said and so I'm super excited
to announce that we're releasing a
library called worker Dom which exposed
the same Dom API that you know love to
you and the frameworks in a web worker
let's take a look at the original
requirements when we went about kind of
building this library I was like hey
Chris can you make it said react works
in the web worker and that was really
all I wanted but I think grace was yeah
you know first the fun of that let's do
something more abstract let's do
something that supports the whole
variety of web programming so what is
worker DOM and makes the full Dom API
available to what worker effectively
this means that you can use your
existing web app and run in the web
worker and it just works with some terms
and conditions obviously
but you know we'll go in there let's
look at the use cases you can use this
to speed up your existing yep app yay
framework authors can use it to speed up
their existing framework with making
minor changes and one particular use
case done I'm very excited about you've
probably heard that third-party
JavaScript other people JavaScript like
your analytics framework that's you know
they're a problem for your site because
you can control them and they might do
bad things wouldn't be nice if you just
ran them on a worker and they kind of
did their own thing but they couldn't
touch your code I think this is an
amazing use case where this library
could be super powerful all right let's
take a look what it does to your program
coming back to this example that Chris
introduced earlier so you know we have
this main thread and we're doing event
processing state determination
processing dumb issues the browser
doesn't work and those things they added
up to 18 milliseconds there's a second
number there it was just the latency
which is 80 milliseconds took 18
milliseconds to react to a user action
that's yellow because that is actually
okay if you're familiar with the rails
model for example actually gives us 50
milliseconds to react to the user so
that's kind of cool right so but we're
janky so let's introduce worker Dom the
first three steps a free application
without changing them go into a
background thread now the whole thing
still takes 18 milliseconds no change
there but the stuff that actually is on
the main thread is now massively reduced
we're now at 10 milliseconds which is
silky smooth and I think the important
part here is that we're now far away
from breaking through the barrier of 60
milliseconds right so now we can run on
a slower device and we still have a lot
of budget to go to make it there right
if we're if we're just about like
scraping against that 16 m/s on an
iPhone X it's not gonna go well and then
in the wild so I think this is really
like a very promising way of building up
vacation I'm excited to see how that's
going to go out let's look at those
terms and conditions really quick now
the library isn't like hundreds and done
so some Dom API design implement
that's cool because you know we can just
do it there are a small number of dumb
API is that cannot be implemented but
there are there are alternatives
provided and then there's a smaller
number of Dom API which can't be
implemented and worker Dom can't really
work with them at all so let's take a
quick look at those last two categories
first of all there unimplemented but
there is an alternative these are
primarily dumb api's that provide
synchronous access to stuff like
completed layout of a page so for
example API many of you will be familiar
with it compounding client rekt so like
hey browser how big is this diff right
when you call that function in the main
thread what the browser will do is will
go run its entire layout pipeline if
that's necessary and it's good like full
in the browser go all the way back and
that's all synchronous that's not
implementable in a worker because
there's no sink access to the Dom so
what we do instead we provide
alternatives they all have a async
suffix so like get burning client direct
async and the returns a promise now you
don't have to change your program much
you just at the async suffix add an
evade before you're using a single way
you should and your program works again
all right so it's a minor change and
there's an important side benefit if you
go and optimize the application one of
the things you're looking out for is
that you don't make these sync layout
calls more than once in a given frame
see if you've make that call it changed
something make a call again you pay a
choice if you order syncs the right way
you only pay it once so by switching to
this async model the framework can
actually schedule stuff at the right
time without you having to worry about
it which is a much more scalable problem
so I think this is the right direction
for the Dom to go anyway these old
synchronous API is from in 1990 it's
just not the right way to do it all
right
I'm implementable without an alternative
these are primarily synchronous methods
on the event like prevent default and
stop propagation now the browser's event
processing model is inherently
synchronous and that means by the time
the worker learns about the click event
entire browser eventually
and that means that you you know you
might call stop propagation but that
doesn't do anything because you know
event processing already rents mean
nothing you can do there's actually
light at the end of the tunnel
transferable events are a thing that
might come to browser soon and that
would kind of fix this situation but for
now basically what it means if you need
these api's and think you know about
your last application how often you
actually call them it's not that much
you have to run that a little bit of a
code on the main thread to make sure
it's the work speaking of working how
does this library actually work so we
don't need to understand all of the guts
of this thing but I thought it'd be
helpful to go over the kind of the
high-level as well as some of the
details that I thought were particularly
interesting during the implementation so
let's start with a high-level we start
off with a main thread in a worker
thread on the main thread we have a
runtime roughly one kilobyte of
JavaScript and this runtime is able to
look at what the DOM is on the current
page in this case we have an element an
HTML element that we would like to
upgrade to run in within the worker
context and inside of that just a single
dip just to make things simple so the
first thing that happens is the runtime
will create a worker for you and load
your JavaScript within that worker now
worker Dom exists within the worker
thread and is able to start processing
your code at this point your code will
create the Dom structure that it would
like to have in the document so we have
a document with our HTML div element and
then there's a lull your code is
finished performing an update to the Dom
in this case we consider hydration so we
might we make sure that that message is
passed along over and applied to the
main thread later as you have input
events or things that need to you take
the Dom like click handlers you will
allow mutations to occur this is very
simple high level and kind of explains
what worker Dom does and how it operates
but let's dive in a little bit more on
hydration so what is hydration hydration
is the conversion of string markup into
usable Dom nodes a helpful way to
understand this is to look at how the
browser actually does this with its
tokenizer
pretend that we have a section element
and in this case because we're using
worker Dom it has an attribute source
that points to the javascript file of
your JavaScript that is actually
represented in the Dom as an HTML
section element inside that we have a
HTML div element because I'm pretty bad
at semantic markup and inside of here
we'll have three child nodes a text node
that says hello world followed by a span
HTML span element with some text inside
of it that says spanner and lastly an
HTML input element so this is how the
browser would tokenize these specific
elements into Dom structures worker Dom
does roughly the same thing however we
need to be able to transmit these
objects between threads so we need a
single interface that makes it easy to
transmit this information that we so we
don't have to have all of these
different class types to understand
between threads so in this case our div
can be represented as a hydrate Abul
node it's got an element type of note
the node type is an element node the tag
name is div we need a unique identifier
so we can reference that node on both
sides of the bridge and whether or not
it's been transferred is actually
incredibly important because once it's
been transferred the format doesn't need
to be as verbose we only need to send a
very small amount of information once
we've transferred it once so we are able
to convert that div element over to a
hydrate able node and you can see how we
could take the same pattern and apply it
to the rest of this Dom structure so now
we're looking at a tree of entirely
hydrate Abul nodes this structure is
transferable between threads and allows
us to send the information in an
efficient way so let's look at an actual
example here's a JSON representation of
that interface I've got the node type
here the node name child nodes that
there's only a single child in this case
and that unique identifier our index and
transferred false so something we've
learned about web workers in this is
that given the same complexity of your
messages a smaller size transmits faster
and is more responsive to end user input
so we need to do some work too this
means this format to ensure that it
remains small independent of the number
of nodes that you give it so we apply a
substitution cipher which is just a
fancy term for
replacement to no name node the node
type child nodes index and transferred
these are all static keys that we
restore and allow us to trim to convert
over our object structure into keys
based on the index of those strings next
we have some false and throughs as
values well those can be represented as
zeros and ones so let's go ahead and do
that and lastly we have now something we
can't do at build time so all those
other transformations could be done at
build time because we know both sides of
the equation at all times but your
markup has different text in it your
markup has different Dom nodes in it
we can't bake in all of the possible
string permutations that your code use
so we create a string pool that will
contain all of the strings that are
needed for your application as you use
them and we only transmit the parts of
the pool that have not yet been received
on both sides of the thread both sides
of the threads so now we're able to
represent this format in a fairly
succinct way and you can see that we're
getting closer and closer and closer to
a pure integer representation of this
structure in the future we'll be able to
move this entirely to a typed array and
that's where we will end up but for now
we've got a fairly efficient format that
has been very little overhead so now
that we've got this format for
individual hydrator we'll nodes we need
to be able to look at what the interface
for hydration itself looks like a little
bit more complex and that we have to
pass that string pull over next mutation
static document would be extremely
boring if that was all we could do we
need to be able to respond to those
input events here we have a span that we
created and a click event listener
that's attached to it
when that happens we were able to then
use the classlist Dom token list method
to toggle a class name as well as change
the style of a different div that is not
defined in this example how does this
work well we use a mutation observer and
because we built the Dom implementation
we could build our own mutation observer
which has super powers
so instead of just being able to modify
things like attribute changes or changes
to the tree structure we can also
observe things like value changes so we
know property changes not just
attributes there was a lot of
information so we had to steal Laurie's
joke we're not actually gonna do it
because Laurie did it I just wanted to
emphasize I just want to emphasize that
we talked about how it works because
it's interesting but one of the magical
things about work Radames I was like
looking at the readme and like where's
the usage statement and it doesn't have
one right like the you just make a
worker and then you say like
document.getelementbyid e or you make
your react component right like it's it
doesn't have an API because it's just
the Dom API and the web worker so I
think that's actually kind of cool
speaking of which do we want to like
show a demo so we're kind of short on
time and so what I'm gonna do is
something akin to this meme I love this
one we're gonna start with the left and
we're gonna move to the owl quickly all
right I've got some demos here so the
first one that we'll go into is a
vanilla Dom implementation so this is
actually the example we talked about
during the slides so we've got hello
world as a text node a span with some
text inside of it and an input element
as I click here you can see changes
occurring this is the least glamorous
demo ever however believe me all of this
is happening in a worker now if I come
here I can type remove and we'll remove
a node next demo that wasn't very
impressive this can't possibly be fast
right we're having to serialize up a
bunch of information transfer between
threads
I thought we'd show something that kind
of pushes the boundaries of what right
performance of the web would be like so
we built a DB Mon implementation if
you're familiar with like which'll Dom
frameworks they all implement DB Mon to
like show how awesome and fast they are
I don't know if this is fast or not
compared to some other frameworks but it
certainly seems to work well on low-end
devices
and just to show that this is not
cheating we'll do a little record and
let's sneak in at the actual snapshot at
work you can see we're fairly close to
60 frames per second across the board
and the code is split directly across
the main thread here and the worker
thread the worker thread is running the
entirety of our JavaScript framework in
this case and that's highlighted by
these kind of light pink categorizations
and the browser is doing its work in the
main thread and you can see that by
these large purple and green streaks
fantastic so we wanted to ensure that
this framework earned that this
technology would work with many
different frameworks not just one or the
other so we implemented the exact same
application and both pre act and react
this is a fake mapping diagram from some
data that I found on the internet a very
abstract map and this is an SVG so as we
modify this we're able to make mutations
to the to the SVG graphic across the
bridge and that example is running
pre-act
let's do the same example but in react
and everything seems to still work by
the way this is running the latest
version of react I'm certain there's
some new things there that I were
supposed to be pretty cool lastly I
thought I'd do an example of to do MVC
since that seems to be the canonical
thing people show when they are
demonstrating a new technology this to
do MVC implementation works pretty well
if I can actually type and this is like
not to video to do MVC written for
worker Dom is just to do MVC running
inside a worker Dom and I can go ahead
and remove an item and you very barely
see that there is the item count is
updating and Dom nodes are being removed
okay great all right so can can you try
this
yes worker Dom we just became available
on github and NPM a few minutes ago
it is still very alpha s software he
goes I think our main goal is not so
like all of you go run and use this in
your production application please don't
eventually do especially and I know lots
of you are here if you maintain a
framework of build tool we really want
to make sure that they work together
with worker Dom that there's no missing
features and but you know some of the
problems might be might be solved I also
want to talk about the quick I still
like why we like personally building
this so we are working on project or
vocal amp and our goal with worker Dom
is to allow authors of M documents to
run their own JavaScript in amp
documents which he currently can't and
that's terrible it's not like JavaScript
and so we all use worker down to do this
and I think this is important for an
open source project so because it's
alpha today but we will make it rock
solid for this use case and so it's
usable for everyone else's and there are
non amp webpages as well yeah and that's
really all we had thank you very much
here's the link to github the slides a
blog post the Christopher
[Applause]